rest in peace people Herman haha dude
that's actually a genius how did he know
his thing was an adult show and then
people were like just like let's make it
for kids and then it became a huge hit
people's playhouse
uh that is crazy
he had cancer I guess uh
see this is the stuff like that drives
me nuts and I don't mean it's his fault
this is the Public's fault when he says
he writes please accept my apology for
not going public with what I've been
facing the last six years Mr Reuben said
in a statement released with the
announcement of his death I've always
felt a huge amount of love and respect
for my friend's fan support I have loved
you all so much and enjoyed making art
for you dude he doesn't owe you that
[__] man he probably just wants to be
alone and do that thing like shout out
to [__] Chadwick Boseman that's his
name right the guy who died of like he
just was like out he was just peace out
did he even say anything he didn't say
anything when he had it and then when he
didn't have it he just pieced out
which is really the way to the the
that's a gangster way to do it
he didn't say [__] dude
it just goes [__]
yeah
peace out
um
but yeah God bless I'm happy with Herman
he was the best rest in peace people
Herman we love we love them man God that
guy was so funny
dude he was a girlfriend and he did that
that is so funny bro haha dude that's
actually genius
wow that's some Beavis and butt head
level funny [__]
ha ha like dude how did he how did he
know crazy crazy crazy
[Music]
congratulations